[Music]
anybody here have a bucket list yeah of
course yeah who doesn't have a book i
know there was a got like a conceptual
bucket list but anybody like right i
have a hundred uh dream goal list wow
100 like you actually wrote it down you
have it dude i can't even complete it
all it was like 70 something right now
because i i knocked out a lot so it's
just refreshed every year
yeah so um it could be anything to like
deep sea fishing or like you know
hobbies or like career goals or whatever
but it's just to kind of like refresh my
mind and being like yeah i did some of
this [ __ ] i'm not a loser i'm checking
off things
i need to write some professional i love
that i'm not a loser reasons why i'm not
a loser i wrote a hundred reasons
i only managed to get to 70.
see i'm not a [ __ ] loser you see that
look at the receipts
i put it back in my pockets deep sea
fishing
i did that for my birthday this year
what a [ __ ] loser let's go dc fishing
have you guys ever been yeah
let's go i want to go man i told look at
alex about it i know
he's gonna be on friday i don't know i
have no idea he's very tasty anybody
else got bucket list i kind of have i
kind of have one now
i want to go hunting once i want to go
that's one of mine too what do you want
to hunt
like humans well i was listening to uh
that sounds fun you guys see jewel was
on joe rogan yeah the singer yeah and
she was explaining her story so she uh
she's a hunter yeah she grew up in
alaska her whole life they don't even
have running water or anything like that
so she was talking about her
relationship with food where if they
like butchered cattle they ate
everything including the blood turned
into blood sausages and so she was just
like and we don't have uh running water
to go to the stream so we don't even a
drop of water is precious to her like
when she's carrying it she's like most
people don't know how heavy water is
because you're carrying in a bottle all
the time and i'm like [ __ ] i do have a
weird relationship with food so i just
want to hunt and eat something that i
killed because this people just go this
is what gets me food yeah they don't
have to [ __ ] murder something cute
yeah yeah i like that part of it
i'm gonna try and see what it feels
rarely eat the most nutritious parts too
yeah all the organs
yeah like the liver and [ __ ] like that
there's like a whole new movement with
people
getting back to that [ __ ] and then um
it's like i think it's a part of the
carnivore or whatever but yeah they're
like yeah humans are meant to eat this
[ __ ]
i just love the idea of my i have a
bloody face i'm holding on to meat and
i'm like i'm really connected
especially stephen this outfit just
chilling send pizza
there's a group of reindeer herders that
actually eat raw [ __ ] reindeer like
that bloody as [ __ ] they just cut the
[ __ ] open and you just see just
the whole family going around and just
digging in all these kids just like
blood all up in their face i want to try
staying with them it's like it's like
reindeer herders of siberia they can eat
it like raw they kill it fresh and then
you just eat it right then and there i
think that's before like the parasites
invaded and stuff but most parasites
exist in the gut anyway so if you
that's why they say like when you handle
like when you dress a a animal or
whatever you don't want to puncture the
guts and all that because that's when
all the bacteria and [ __ ] can get into
the
parasites don't really exist
in the lean meat yeah but i do want to
hunt i also want to hang around a bunch
of kids that [ __ ] eat deer but um you
guys see those pictures bros
crazy raw deer roger there's this
terminally ill man
uh
terminally ill puts together a bucket
list but he ends up getting why'd you
say it twice like it's a punchline
terminator
try let me try it again terminal
we
what about this sick ass dude like it's
a punchline i'm joking for you dude
i'm just gonna awkwardly wait it out so
i move on with this terminally ill man
terminally ill arrested after mooning a
speed camera to take off his bucket list
so he spent the rest of his time in jail
couldn't [ __ ] completely
die
mooning a speed camera at the end of the
article
i like how that was his bucket list dude
let me [ __ ] show them my [ __ ] so
so what city did this happen
look this is i'm gonna show ryan just to
make sure this is what he looks like
that's what he looks like okay what is
his name daryl or darrell
so daryl meat com age 55 compiled a list
of things he wanted to do before he dies
after being told last month he had
multiple system atrophy a terminal
condition that affects the nervous
system with bungee jumping and
parachuting also on the list stanford
wasn't nervous at all yeah the retired
university lecturer and former nurse
managed to take off mooning a speed
camera last friday when he showed his
behind to a van in warchester for sure
warchestershire wore chesterscheid
worcester worcestershire how do you say
that his name is
nah man there's a way to say it right i
know it is
chestershire
my mom can say it i swear to god
call her up she's the only person i've
ever been able to say who i've heard
[Laughter]
so the police officers obviously failed
to see the funny stuff he's calling his
mom bro he's not like-minded
hi ma uh real quick you're on a live
show right now i got to know how do you
say worcestershire sauce
which
sister cider sauce
yeah is that it
yeah what's it where is this
worcestershire sauce yeah
there it is
okay that's how you say it
okay okay love you
gotta go
she said it worse than us i think she
sighed because that's the first time
i've caught her in like four months
she was less confident than we were
let's not [ __ ] call your mom
i watched the documentary on this [ __ ] i
watched the documentary they said it
right i forgot what her voice sounded
like
are you sure that was her
damn i haven't talked to my mom in like
a year we're just just shy or something
we should all call our moms right now
and ask when i was a kid i swear to god
it sounded perfect when she said it
trust me that's going down the drain my
mom just called the stick sauce that's
what she's cause it's called it four
chinese people love that [ __ ] right they
use it for like i don't even know my mom
puts on our steaks and everything bro
she loves it i don't even [ __ ] know
my mom knows what that is i like it it's
great in the michelada as well i think
it's like whoa malt wheat yeah yeah
there it is [ __ ] my wheat [ __ ] anyways
we saw the police failed to see the
funny side of it and 20 minutes later
three police cars pulled up outside me
comes home and he refused to let them in
so they kicked down the garden gate and
wrestled them to the ground to pour a
[ __ ] mooning picture in phone footage
recorded by his wife
uh the dad of two mekong can be heard
telling officers i'm terminally ill i
won't be able to breathe like this this
is ridiculous i mooned a speed camera
and a female officer then replies well
that's a significant statement that you
have just made to us oh my wow we got
her we got him dead the rights
[ __ ] ratted him yikes bro cops are so
[ __ ] wack sometimes come on there
must be no crime in this town man dude
imagine arresting a guy like this yeah
because they know the camera yeah they
know what the crime is
and they're in the car going we're going
to take this [ __ ] down
it was like the nice ass they saw that
day and they're like [ __ ] had it you
know what i mean how do they id the guy
how do they find them they probably have
an ass id
his id
they're gonna ask him to [ __ ] show
his butt cheeks or maybe
yep that's him if it fit the description
he said uh it's something i've always
wanted to do because i've been caught by
them a couple of times for silly speeds
like 35 miles per hour in a 30 zone and
always bugged me okay this is the most
boring town in america yeah that's
what's going on
it's yeah the sauce that sounds really
inflow by the way thank you so you know
what it doesn't matter how we say it
because the cops in this town are narcs
so yeah
dude type that [ __ ] in youtube see what
comes out i guarantee you someone
[ __ ] said it right sound of you know
all right type in worcestershire and
then write irish accents
it's much shorter than it's spelled yeah
you know i think so it's like something
super short like worcester or something
this is a town that pops you for over
watering your garden yeah that's true
because we're dealing with a drought
citywide hoa i did i did enjoy that
earlier question though what else does
anybody have on a bucket list dude i'll
take right now i was just telling this
to nikki yesterday and it's not even
that big biggest sum of money but i
wanted i want to bet a 5 000 bet on a
super bowl just one time on a winning
team
yeah whichever team i think is going to
win just one time how many years have
you almost pulled the trigger on that
never never has happened but um that's a
big [ __ ] bet though i know but that'd
be the most fun game of your life right
yeah yeah yeah yeah or the most hated
one well even then right yeah yeah true
but it just gives you snakes and you're
like would it matter if your team is in
the uh super bowl or i ideally that's
what it would be but you know
worcestershire
worcestershire
shirt
worcestershire
worcestershire
worcestershire change the name god damn
annoying they should sparrow sauce or
something something that everybody can
say meanwhile the city of worcestershire
is like what the [ __ ] steve no [ __ ] you
worcestershire ruined our town
[Laughter]
5 000
you can do that right now man no i know
but that's but i'm not it's um you don't
feel like you deserve it yeah yeah yeah
that's true i'm not gambling yet until i
make a million yeah i'm just not gonna
it just doesn't look cause because i
know what i could do with money right
because like it took like my car money
and turned it into a really nice moment
i can't believe you're such a loser for
doing it i know i'm an idiot but scammed
you got scammed dude you couldn't even
call him a loser and then
in the meantime i know what i could do
with five grand so i'm gonna hold off on
that until a later date but yeah that's
true that's all that's why i don't
gamble what about you dude yeah [ __ ]
bucket lister i wanna i want i really
really wanna do all those like really
crazy human like festivals and events
like when i did the running with the
bulls in spain i was like this is one of
the greatest things i've ever done but
like to replicate that again it's kind
of like i don't know how to do that so
it's like going to like the halle
festival in india or going to like the
tomatina in spain or going to like
you know um what's that color one when
they throw color dust on you holy holly
if you go to one of those can you let me
know i want to go to one of those things
that's all i'm saying right they just
seem really i'm [ __ ] ignorant did you
go to burning man i didn't yet but it's
digital now oh [ __ ] off is it really
what does that mean not the same
so they don't burn the thing it's at the
metal verse
[Applause]
you gotta like not shower for three days
and get [ __ ] exactly like i love
doing i love doing things like i've been
like lightning and bottom stuff so
lightning bolt human experiences and not
just like musical concerts but like
those kind of like moments where you put
yourself in a very raw extreme kind of
condition for a short period of time
you've never been to a lantern festival
my sister bought her tickets
on her twice dude i went to that and i
was like yeah i'm never doing this [ __ ]
again
damn it
i thought it was gonna be good i know
right it's like what is it it does like
everyone you like you like those uh
flying lanterns that like will hover in
the air but i feel like before like
asian people used to do it to [ __ ]
commemorate like ancestors or anything
like that now it's just like a giant
just to do human beings that just see a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of lights in the sky in
vegas you're supposed to write what you
want to have happen on the lantern or
whatever and then you release it in the
sky and then all ends up in the ocean
dude that's what happens so it's a
littering festival and when you're
walking out of there you're like
stepping over all the litter like it's
[ __ ] hilarious all the lanterns that
fell back there yeah yeah yeah because
they fall back down that's like three
stepping over all these [ __ ] dreams
you're stepping on and over everyone's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you